according to the Greek timeline if they
can do this then are you know before
August the 20th they can ratify this
through Parliament are the European
Parliament's you know other parliaments
in Europe at can do likewise and then
you can get a disbursement before August
the 20th in order to repay that ECB loan
what the Greeks really want to avoid is
another bridge loan because essentially
they are you know from the Greek
government point of view they want to
just be done and dusted with this now
before the Greek government is hoping to
get concessions out of their your area
partners and I think that's pretty clear
now it's off the table there's no reason
to do to enter into another round of
brinksmanship to wait to the last minute
and in fact they're quite keen to get
this wrapped up early so they don't face
more talk of a grexit etc that came
along when they when they wait at the
very last minute beforehand they wanted
to be a done deal Greece is doing
reasonably better compare that to
Ukraine if if a smaller nation is not
part of EU it has a big problem and this
is what necessary then in Greece had an
opportunity to walk out of your own on
July 12 then I didn't want it they don't
want to so it just tells you that there
are more implications for you know a
humanitarian ground for eurozone future
of eurozone and economically i should
say for eurozone
there is generally a more optimistic
tone this time both from the Greek side
and from the institutional side and a
thing also that the Greek government is
it has been a lot more willing this time
to actually get the work done which has
been the criticism of them all the way
through so yes tip press wants to avoid
a bridge deal wants to go straight to a
full bailout and there is a degree of
optimism abroad that yeah that might
actually be possible this time
what the elections would produce would
be if you like a probably a national
unity government that would have almost
a referendum effect you know I I support
suppresses dealings with the
institutions in this and that would be
kind of a broad coalition with most of
the left wing of his own party either
officially out and in another party or
effectively and so I think that kind of
consensus couldn't probably would have
some sort of bright Monday to do that